let's get to audience questions for the
week first question hey David what is
the best argument against equality of
outcome I'm going to answer this
question but I feel like I need to make
a sort of disclaimer which is that very
few people are actually arguing for
total equality of outcome it's mostly a
straw man and those who like to talk
about equality of outcome versus
equality of opportunity many of I like
to talk about it but I'm not straw
Manning equality of outcome many of them
straw man equality of outcome as if
there's this huge movement calling for
total equality of outcome other than
socialists and communists and even they
accept some variability and outcome in
many cases almost no one actually thinks
that we should have equality of outcome
in the economy in society but a few
thoughts on this number one just because
there's some inequality doesn't mean
that that's fundamentally unfair what I
believe is completely unfair is that you
have such inequality that you have
people who are literally hoarding money
with tax advantage at tax advantaged
mechanisms for doing so who have no use
for that money whatsoever and who's
hoarding of that money is acutely
negative for the economy while there are
others who are literally dying of hunger
in the United States that degree of
inequality is unfair and it's bad for
everybody that's involved some
inequality I don't believe is unfair and
fundamentally the reason why is that
there's inequality in the results of any
human phenomena when you look at life
expectancy when you look at sporting
results when you look at achievement on
math and science even if you give
everybody all the tutoring that they
need in math you're still not going to
get total equality of outcomes so I
don't think that some inequality is
fundamentally unfair I think it becomes
a question of inequality versus
unfairness and then the other thing I
think is
to consider aside from the fact that it
would be because I don't you know people
would argue against gay marriage saying
it's unnatural I disagreed I mean
homosexuality exists and who knows how
many thousand species I disagreed with
the unnatural argument but I also
thought that it was a bad argument
whether things are or aren't quote
natural however it's defined that's not
a good enough reason for me to decide
something should or shouldn't be illegal
or accepted in society so number one is
that this equality of outcome doesn't
happen doesn't occur naturally in the
world but that in and of itself is not a
good enough reason to say we shouldn't
be for equality of outcome let's
actually ask the question would equality
of outcome be good in society and the
answer is what kind right
what kind if we're talking about an
inequality of outcome where the poor and
middle class do much much better we
raised the bottom and we reduce the
difference between the top and the
bottom and we use whatever economic
mechanism that we determine is the right
one to increase well-being then you can
have some inequality and that's okay if
you're saying we need equality of
outcome in that everybody gets their
shot at being senator or something like
that that's not an equality of outcome
that I would get behind so just saying
equality of outcome good bad indifferent
we need to know what we're talking about
we need to understand how it is that
that equality would be achieved and then
we can figure out does equality of
outcome makes sense or not and what I
think we would quickly realize is that
in many endeavors in life equality of
outcome wouldn't actually even be the
right target but I want to go back to
where I started very few people are
actually calling for total equality of
outcome in the economy in other
endeavors and to pretend as though
there's this big equality of outcome
movement is fundamentally deceptive